not only is joe biden's moratorium on
evictions unconstitutional
it also hurts small and family-owned
businesses around the country
the brookings institute found that about
40 percent of rental properties are
owned by mom-and-pop landlords
many of whom rely on their tenants rent
payments to pay their own bills and
mortgages
where's biden's compassion for them jen
sidorova is one of those landlords as
well as a policy analyst for the reason
foundation she joins me now
jen tell me a little bit about your
situation
yeah but i'm a landlord here in buffalo
a working class town
a very diverse town with lots of
immigrants just like me
so what i do is i rent out part of my
house and i live in one of the units
rent out the others and you know it's
really been hard it's been keeping me up
at night because
i'm afraid to rent out my units now
because people might not pay
and there's other landlords like me i've
talked to a lot of other women landlords
around new york
and there is people who sacrifice child
care or even paying their own utilities
or mortgages because of this
unprecedented measure it really
represents to me a war on small business
on the part of the biden administration
because
you know in your situation there could
be a number of people
in similar situations who would end up
selling out to larger firms who can
afford to
rent at very inexpensive uh prices at
this moment
in order to scoop up a lot of these
properties and
go get through this period in order to
rent it out themselves
is this something that you've heard from
fellow landlords in new york
well you know what i hear is that a lot
of people are just going out of business
exactly as you said or maybe they're
switching to the model that's
more like a vacation rental you know
short-term rental
other than long-term and what it's
really doing it's that's pushing
young people or vulnerable people who we
might normally give you know a break
and give them a chance we simply cannot
do this anymore because we cannot run
the risk of having somebody living in
our property for free
and us having to pay you know mortgage
and utilities and then keeping it up
it's just impossible for somebody who
only has maybe two or three
units i know that you work for a reason
so i'm sure you're familiar with
all manner of usage of the invisible
hand or
the things that are unseen isn't this
kind of a perfect example of something
like that playing out within
our economic policy that what is seen is
the president going out there and saying
even if this is unconstitutional i'm
going to do the compassionate thing for
all these uh different americans
meanwhile he's crushing the very people
who are necessary for our economy to be
able to make a comeback
right they made landlords villains but
honestly
i am an immigrant i moved to this
country when i was 18
i worked every day i paid my taxes
it's been like 15 years since i was able
to afford a property and now it's my
time to
you know build some generational wealth
and invest
and the government is taking it right
out of my hands are they robbing me out
of my american dream
and honestly i feel like i speak on
behalf of all the hard-working
immigrants in this country
this is simply not the america we signed
up for
it really is not what you signed up for
and it's it's
incredibly infuriating to see the type
of praise
that the president was receiving from
major media entities the washington post
in particular
as opposed to the critique that i think
would highlight the ramifications of
what he's actually doing jen sidorova
thank you so much for joining me tonight
thank you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else